I mean look I think Elon is I don't
think I'm even a great example but I
think Elon would be the great example of
this which is like you know look he's a
guy who from every every day of his life
from the day he started making money at
all he just Plows in the into the next
thing
um and so I think I think money is
definitely an enabler for satisfaction
money applied to happiness leads people
down very dark paths yeah
very destructive Avenues uh money
applied to satisfaction I think could be
it is a real tool
um I always by the way I was like you
know Elon is the case study for Behavior
but the other thing that it's always
really made me think is Larry Larry Page
was asked one time what his approach to
philanthropy was and he said oh I'm just
my my philanthropic plan is just give
all the money to Elon
right uh well let me actually ask you
about Elon what are your
um you've interacted with quite a lot of
successful engineers and business people
what do you think is special about Elon
we talked about Steve Jobs What uh
what do you think is special about him
as a leader as an innovator yeah so the
the core of it is he's a he's he's back
to the future so he he is he is doing
the most Leading Edge things in the
world but with a with a really deeply
old school approach
um and so to find comparisons to Elon
you need to go to like Henry Ford and
Thomas Watson and Howard Hughes and
Andrew Carnegie right um Leila Stanford
um John D Rockefeller right you need to
go to the what we're called the
Bourgeois capitalist it's like the
hardcore business owner operators who
basically built you know basically built
industrialized Society
um Vanderbilt um and it's a level of
Hands-On commitments
um and uh depth um in the business
um coupled with an absolute priority uh
towards truth um and towards
um how to put Science and Technology uh
time to First principles that is just
like absolutely it was just like
unbelievably absolute he really is ideal
that he's only ever talking to Engineers
like he does not tolerate yes
let's anybody I've ever met
um he wants ground truth on every single
topic
um and he runs his businesses directly
day to day devoted to getting to ground
truth in every single topic so uh
you think it was a good decision for him
to buy Twitter I have developed a view
in life did not second guess Elon Musk
I know this is going to sound great
crazy and unfounded but well I mean uh
he's got a quite a track record I mean
look the car was a crazy I mean the car
was I mean look he's done a lot of
things that seem crazy starting a new
car company in the United States of
America the last time somebody really
tried to do that was the 1950s and it
was called Tucker automotive and it was
such a disaster they made a movie about
what a disaster it was
um and then Rockets like who does that
like that's there's obviously no way to
start a rocket company like those days
are over and then to do those at the
same time
so after he pulled those two off like
okay fine like like this is one of my
areas of like whatever opinions I had
about that is just like okay clearly or
not relevant like this is you just you
at some point you just like bet on the
person and in general I wish more people
would lean on celebrating and supporting
versus deriding and destroying oh yeah I
mean look he drives resentment like it's
like he is a magnet for resentment
um like his critics are the most
miserable like resentful people in the
world like it's almost a perfect match
of like the most idealized you know
technologists you know of the century
coupled with like just his critics are
just bitter as can be I mean it's it's I
mean it's it's sort of very Darkly uh
comic to watch
well he uh he fuels the fire of that by
being an on Twitter at times and
which is fascinating to watch the drama
of human civilization given our cult
roots
just fully on fire he's running a cult
say that very successfully